Hey guys, Pete here. welcome to my new
Game of Thrones Season 8 series. as I've
been caught up in all the preseason
excitement I've been doing what I
imagine most people are doing right now
trying to figure out how I think the
series will end this isn't an easy task
in a story that has such a big world
built up around it there's so many
possible directions things could go and
frankly most of them have problems that
I can't get past when I'm trying to
think my way through it in this series
I've decided to do something different
to look at all the problems related to
the major plot points I will lay those
out you guys can tell me what you think
and perhaps we can move in the direction
of making sense of it all before I get
started I just want to say I think this
is a pretty good problem to have part of
why I still find this all interesting is
because there are so many layers to the
story we have strong characters with
real conflicts unreliable history magic
religion prophecy and political
maneuvering because the incomplete book
series is so popular and so thoroughly
discussed and theorized about it's
pretty easy to find yourself in a rabbit
hole where you think you have finally
found that one thing that makes it all
come together
spoiler alert you haven't because that
thing affects other things and what
about this you get the idea there's a
lot going on and there are no easy
answers in this video series we'll look
at the problems together and we will
start with the threat that is on
everyone's minds right now the night
King let's jump in one of the biggest
problems we have with the night king is
that he isn't exactly a character from
the books in fact he sounds like a
character mentioned in the books but we
can't be sure what that means because
george RR martin the author said this as
for the night's king the form i prefer
in the books he is a legendary figure
akin to land the clever and Brandon the
Builder and no more likely to have
survived to the present day than they
have so the problem here is that we
don't have a character who has been
fleshed out in the books to base our
thoughts on it's very likely that he has
parts of this night's King story
incorporated into his but we really just
don't know the show is far beyond the
books and
the white walkers to us and they haven't
even shown us that much
we have religious zealots like
Melisandre and followers of the Lord of
Light that think he is the great other
or the dark force opposite of the Lord
of Light but we know this isn't exactly
right either depending on how you see
the gods and how you know people
following religions relates to magic
which is a real force in this world I
think we can all agree that it isn't as
cut and dry as the zealots think it is
so that's this up a situation where some
people who think they know the answers
but they're probably actually wrong
we'll talk about this more in relation
to some of the other problems so I'll
leave it there for right now the next
problem is that we know he was a man
that was turned into the night king but
we don't know who he was
and that means we don't know what he
wants we do have a pretty good
explanation of why he was created in the
first place which was to destroy the
first men who were encroaching on the
children of the forest land in
destroying weirwood trees which are
basically their gods Leif told Brandes
and they went as far as giving us
history and lore segments to back that
up history and lore of course are the
DVD extras that they put on you know
with the seasons when they release them
so there was pretty good information
there about the conflict between the
children and the forest and the first
men how they had to join together and
form the pact and all those other things
that we already know from reading the
books that means that it is important to
keep in mind that this is part of his
motivation to kill humans he was
designed for it and we've seen him do
that at the same time there's something
else obviously going on and who he was
maybe important or maybe it's not Brad's
the only character left who might be
able to figure out who he was I mean the
children of the force would know that
but it isn't clear if there are any more
of them left alive in our story of
course this is a problem in and of
itself but I don't think there is any
way we can say if we will see more
children in the show outside of them
actually showing up in it bran is the
key to figure out how to defeat the
night king I feel sure about that but
whether that includes
finding out who he was before he was
turned could go either way and maybe
that we won't learn more about that
until the prequel series comes out and I
mentioned this in other videos that used
to be one of my biggest fears is that we
would never find out who the night king
was or what the truth behind his
motivation was now I don't feel as
worried about that since we're probably
gonna learn a lot about that in the
upcoming series as for what he wants
besides destroying humanity we have the
interview with the actor who says
directly that he didn't want to be the
night king and that he wants revenge
that could just mean that he wants to
wipe out the children of the forest the
show killed off a bunch of the children
in the holded or episode without giving
much attention to them and then didn't
really mention them after that before
that happened I had always assumed they
would play a big role in the end game
and the books the Isle of faces seems
really important and for a long time
I've imagined that the major battle with
the night king would happen there as we
gear up for season 8 this seems pretty
unlikely I mean it could happen if Mira
brings her father Howland Reed back to
Winterfell or if bran sees something in
the weirwood Network but nothing I've
seen leading up to the season has given
me hope on these points playing out in
the TV show it would take a lot of
explaining at this point to build that
up and there isn't a lot of time left in
the series the safer bet is the Battle
of Winterfell happens and it either ends
with the night Kings defeat or the White
Walkers overrun Winterfell without
killing off the main players on the side
of the living knowing that means it's
less likely that we'll learn anything
about the night king that doesn't come
from bran
I tend to think this means that we'll
just get bits and pieces related to how
to defeat him because that's where we
are were in a battle that's definitely
going to happen so I'd be remiss if I
didn't mention the night's king the
legendary figure from the book because
he likely was a star or at least he's
from the same bloodline one of the cool
things about this series is that history
is unreliable so we don't really know
much of
we just have stories that have been
passed down for generations in that
scenario it's possible that he wants
revenge against house start something up
really quickly you know he was handed
over there was some negotiations and so
there is a possibility that he's been
sitting up north with the chip on his
shoulder what just wanting to destroy
how stark that is definitely possible
either way I don't think that that is
the overriding purpose of what he's
going to mean to the end game so it's
definitely a problem as to who he is and
what he wants and that leads into the
next one which is that he doesn't
communicate not in the common tongue
anyway it's like not in a way that he's
just gonna come out and discuss terms
with the side of the living of course
brand can possibly communicate with him
inside the weirwood Network I think the
night king has access to the way I mean
I think the show is pretty much shown
that whenever he touched brand inside
there but beyond that I think he
probably does similar things inside the
weirwood Network that the children of
the forest do and I think it's given us
some evidence for that and that he
waited for Danny to come with her
dragons and he strategized the whole
setup for getting the dragon so it was
clear that he had throwing weapons he
could have wiped them out on their
little island but he used them as bait
to get a dragon instead that leads me to
believe that he has some ability to see
what's going on outside of his own area
there and he knew that she was going to
show up but yes communication is a
problem it makes it seem a lot less
likely that there will be some sort of
agreement or pact which is a bit of a
problem based on it pigeonholes him in
relation to the last couple of problems
that stand out to me right on the
surface
the next problem is that it's been set
up that if you kill him
that will kill all the other whites that
have been turned the white walkers that
he created and therefore ending the
entire war that seems a little bit too
easy not easy in the sense that there
won't be a great battle leading up to
that but it just seems like it's a bit
of a simple solution no it's only been
hinted at that that's what will happen
based on things that we've seen I
imagine that there is something more
like it's just not getting him one on
one with John John having blue and steel
striking a deathblow and then everything
goes back to normal and that leads right
into the final major problem that I see
with the knight King in relation to
season 8 and that is that he can't win
no matter what you think is going to
happen unless you're just bucking the
idea of the story as it's been told so
far you really can't believe that this
whole series is going to end with the
knight King on top like the Song of Ice
and Fire is not a story about how fire
was not good enough or strong enough to
overcome ice and the whole thing ends in
a winter that never ends right I mean
come on so we know he's going to lose
and that's a problem if you're anything
like me you've spent so much time
reading The Dream's
in the books over and over again looking
for clues trying to figure out who this
guy is and now that we're at the end of
the TV series version he's been set up
as the great evil the big bad and we
just know in our hearts that he's not
going to come out on top
this is more of a storytelling problem I
guess but it creates a situation where
there has to be some sort of payoff like
we have to almost feel bad for the
knight King when he dies and because
like I said him taking him out destroys
the other side that leaves a lot more
story to be told in order for it to be a
satisfying conclude
of course there are a lot of different
theories out there at this point I don't
think it's worth delving into them too
deeply of course some people thinks he
wants to take a queen other people think
that John is necessary that John will
have to sacrifice and take his place
essentially becoming the new Knight King
I don't think any of those things are
going to happen I'm not saying that they
couldn't happen I guess we need to also
address the idea that maybe bran is the
night king but I think it's gonna come
down to something a little more
straightforward and we know he has to
lose so that means that in order for
there to be balance in the ending of the
story that the other side can't exactly
just win either and as we get into the
rest of this series I'll talk about that
because it relates to everyone else's
story and the problems I see there but I
wanted to start off with this one the
night King is something that I've
thought about I've read about videos
about in the past and now that we're
getting to the end it's just sort of
like wow there it is he's going to go
down and that's the one reality that we
can kind of Bank on for what it's worth
I don't think that it's going to be
surah high kind of Danny gets sacrificed
by John kind of situation I'm leaning
towards the night King not winning the
Battle of Winterfell outright may be
destroying Winterfell probably
destroying Winterfell but part of me
thinks that he might not even be there I
think it would be pretty kick-ass if he
just took Viserion down to the Isle of
faces and started destroying the trees
that are there and there's a big battle
there and there's a big battle there
between him and the order of the green
men but like I said I don't think
there's going to be I don't think it's
been set up in the TV show to go that
direction also I do have an idea of what
his purpose is I'm just sort of leaving
that out on purpose so that I can bring
it up in other videos and in our
discussion but having said that I mean
it's pretty much a thing they could go
in so many directions like I said in the
beginning that pretty much every time I
get to a point where I think I know how
things are going to go
another idea comes up and I think well
maybe not and you know that's just how
this story is so I'm looking forward to
it one way or the other so we'll just
leave it at that and you guys can tell
me what you think how do you think the
show is gonna get through these problems
how do we get an ending where it makes
sense and we're happy at the end of the
day let me know in the comments I think
the next one in this series will be
about the Iron Throne then I'll go
through individual characters so check
back for that if you want to follow
along with the series you know what to
do
thanks for watching I will talk to you
soon